quand et gilet jaune enfilez sac
poubelle à la main pas de grasse matinée
ce samedi à magny les hameaux et voisins
le bretonneux ce matin-là une
cinquantaine de personnes se sont
répartis en petits groupes pour nettoyer
leur commune c'est la deuxième année que
l'opération world cleanapp day est
organisé à saint quentin en yvelines ce
à mobiliser citoyens sur la question a
pas de geste civique sur la question de
la préservation de l'environnement et du
cadre de vie c'est l'occasion de faire
un geste pour
nettoyer un petit peu l'environnement
dans lequel on vit puis c'est l'occasion
de se retrouver autour de d'une action
citoyenne la protection de
l'environnement ça commence aussi par là
de nettoyer les déchets de pas laisser
traîner dans la nature des choses qui
sont longues à ceux à se décomposer
durant plusieurs heures ils sillonnent
la ville à la recherche de déchets en
tout genre avec cette année un résultat
plutôt positif après confinement n'a
senti qu'ils avaient moins de petits
déchets de moins d'incivilités du
quotidien par contre plus de gros dépôts
sauvages malheureusement à cause du coc
vide on avait beaucoup de masques en
fait qui traînait un petit peu partout
dans la ville qui sont volés qui était
dans les dents les arbustes là cette
année on est très surpris parce qu'il ya
pas de masque même si un petit objet
répond toujours à l'appel sur défunt
michael
et du banc c'est super mis en place est
ici l'année dernière plus de 8 millions
700 mille mégots ont été récoltés à
l'occasion de cette journée une
initiative qui permet également de
sensibiliser les plus jeunes à
l'environnement c'est eux qui
fictivement auront lors la datura à
nettoyer donc on essaie de les
accompagner pour qu'ils puissent être
sensibilisés
ils ramassent des déchets c'est bien
pour la planète voile envira non les
plantes les animaux au bout du circuit
des équipes mettent en commun leurs
récoltes pour faire le tri des déchets
et à 8 km les constats sont les mêmes
pour voisins le bretonneux nous avons
ramassé énormément de mégots de
cigarettes et énormément de plastique et
ça c'est beaucoup trop beaucoup trop il
va falloir travailler beaucoup là dessus
pour font en sorte d'en avoir de moins
en moins jusqu'à plus du tout trois
mètres cubes de déchets ont été récoltés
à voisins le bretonneux dans la commune
des poubelles ont été répartis un peu
partout dans la ville et des cendriers
pédagogique devrait voir le jour dans
peu de temps